[Music]
we are pleased to announce the
nomination for the Screen Actors Guild
Award we'll be announcing 13 awards this
morning award season is in full swing
the SAG nominations are out it's a
really amazing group of talent really I
am Telling You so diverse and talented
I've been watching all the shows and I'm
just excited for the most part the noms
look a lot like the Golden Globes list
there were a couple sweet surprises on
the TV side
sterling K Brown landed two nods one for
the People vs OJ Simpson and one for
this is us I love what I do
so much and to be recognized by my peers
and this way is very difficult
concentrate
Bryce Dallas Howard was recognized for
her work on Black Mirror and finger
things star Millie Bobby Brown is up for
female actor in a Drama Series in terms
of it's nubs no love for loving and
swallow land lost out on an all cast
nomination maybe it means I doubt it
yeah though Ryan Gosling and Emma Stone
is still received individual nods the
23rd annual Screen Actors Guild Awards
airs Sunday January 29th on at CES and
TNT
[Music]
you